During spring 2018, tens of thousands of teachers walked out of their schools.
These walkouts attracted extensive media attention,
prompting RJ Martin and I to examine
coverage in five major newspapers.
What did we find? A mix of good and bad.
The good: National papers published
a total of 59 articles on the strikes.
Of these, 56 had impartial
headlines and leads. Impressive!
The bad: The 254 quotes in the
59 stories favored the strikes
by a 5 to 1 margin — a ratio that
far exceeded actual public opinion.
Meanwhile, affected families were almost never quoted.
Worse: The coverage did little to
put compensation in context
or to explain how teacher salaries stack up against median household income in their state.
Stories also rarely noted the cost of
generous health care and pension plans.
And that's a problem, because these benefits
are a big part of any serious
conversation about teacher pay.
Newspapers can do better, and
with more strikes looming,
they'll have plenty of chances.
How do you think media covered the teacher strikes?
Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.